- Thanks to Brilliant for
keeping LegalEagle in the air.
Get 20% off your annual subscription
by using the link in the description.
On March 11, 2020, the
World Health Organization
declared COVID-19 a pandemic.
- WHO has been assessing this
outbreak around the globe.
COVID-19 can be
characterized as a pandemic.
- This virus is not
only making people sick,
but it's upending our daily lives.
That includes canceling vacations,
postponing events, and
upending employment.
Did you plan a wedding that
now needs to be postponed?
Did you have to cancel
your European vacation
after the travel ban?
Is your small business
suddenly behind on rent?
Well, today we're gonna
talk about how you might
be able to use contract law
and insurance agreements
to get refunds and even relief.
Let me start with a disclaimer
that probably goes without saying,
but I'm going to say it
because I'm a lawyer.
Nothing in this video should
be construed as legal advice.
Nothing I say creates an
attorney-client relationship
with you, the viewer.
If you have a
coronavirus-related question,
you should contact your own lawyer,
or better yet, your doctor.
Now, with that out of the way,
I do want to give you one more warning.
What I'm going tell you
is incredibly powerful.
But I want you to use
this information wisely.
Let's say you had a wedding
scheduled for April,
and maybe that won't be happening now.
So naturally you're gonna want
to cancel with the caterers,
the band, and the photographer.
But remember, those are people too.
That's how they make their living,
and it's going to be hard
times ahead for those people.
Everyone in the service
industry is going to suffer.
A photographer can't work from home.
No one's going to be
hiring bands for parties
that won't be happening
for the foreseeable future.
Unless you live in Florida.
But it might be the
same with your landlord.
Sure, your apartment
building might be part
of a giant conglomerate
owned by BlackRock,
but it also might be the only
building owned by a family.
There are always downstream consequences.
So, sure, no one's going to blame you
for having to look out for yourself.
But remember that your
actions effect others too,
and everyone is going to be struggling
for the foreseeable future.
So with that business out of the way,
today we're going to be
covering such sexy legal topics
as terms and conditions, force majeure,
and insurance riders.
Oh yeah.
(triumphant music)
So let's start with the basics.
When you make a reservation
when you buy plane tickets,
or when you purchase
anything on the internet,
you agree to abide by
certain terms and conditions.
You can find out what you agree to
by clicking on the terms
and conditions page
of most websites or
reviewing whatever document
they send you by email or snail mail.
This document contains all of the legalese
that you didn't review and
merely glanced at, at best.
And unfortunately, this is
generally a binding contract
that applies to you.
The good news is that
you can learn to think
like a lawyer to help
yourself out of a jam,
often using the exact same
language that you find
in those pages of text that
you absolutely did not read.
Don't try and fool anyone.
You didn't read it.
Now, if you made travel reservations,
you should immediately review
the terms and conditions pages
to see what terms applied originally,
and whether that company
has updated their policies
because of the coronavirus.
For example, Airbnb is the
original travel disrupter
and they disrupted the travel industry
by creating a website
that lets people rent out
their homes and extra rooms to travelers.
Now, generally Airbnb allows their hosts
to set their own cancellation policy.
Some hosts require a deposit
and more than 48 hours notice to cancel.
Other hosts are more strict,
taking the guest deposit
if the person cancels for any reason.
But that changed on March
14 when Airbnb notified
hosts and guests that it was updating
their extenuating circumstances policy.
The site now allows all guests
to cancel all reservations
without penalty anywhere in the world
as long as the reservation for the travel
was between March 14 and April 14.
And as things go on and
potentially get worse,
that policy may be updated again.
A lot of hosts are very
unhappy with this result,
since many depend on the
income to afford rent
or pay for their mortgage.
But if you're a guest,
however, you might be able
to cancel your reservation
and monitor the host
to ensure that they comply
with Airbnb's new policy.
It's really important not only to check
the original terms, but also
if anything has been updated.
Business Insider has
compiled a list of hotels
which have updated their
cancellation policies,
and I'll put the link to that
down in the description below.
Many hotels run by groups
like Disney, Hilton, and Hyatt
are waiving cancellation fees for travel
booked through April,
and if you have travel dates
that are later in the year
you might want to jump
on the phone immediately.
Because you know things are
bad when travel companies
are voluntarily relaxing
their contractual terms.
If the customer service
people are giving you
a hard time one pro tip is to use
the government warnings to your advantage.
For example, the WHO, the
World Health Organization,
declared coronavirus a pandemic,
and experts are unsure for
how long extreme measures
like social distancing, isolation,
and quarantine will last.
The State Department has
issued travel advisories
and warnings for certain countries.
State governors have prohibited gatherings
and are locking down
huge swaths of people,
and when you're talking
to customer service
you can site these
warnings as evidence to why
you cannot travel and should get a refund.
We'll go into detail about
these specific legal doctrines
that you might use to bootstrap
some of these warnings
in dealing with customer
service or other companies
that you might have to cancel
in order to get a refund.
Now, not all travel or
commercial companies
are going to be as gracious as the ones
that are voluntarily rolling back
their cancellation policies.
But if you dig into the
terms and conditions
you might find specific
language or fine print
that says something along the lines of
"the company is not
responsible for any injury,
"loss, or damage to
person or property, death,
"delay, or inconvenience
in connection with
"the provision of any goods
or services occasioned
"by or resulting from,
but not limited to,"
and this is the important part,
"acts of God or force majeure."
That brings us to one of the
most important legal doctrines
that you're probably
going to be dealing with
in this particular situation.
Acts of God and force majeure.
Now, force majeure is
basically like a magic spell
used by dark wizards called lawyers.
Force majeure!
(exciting music)
I'm just kidding.
It's a very dry contractual
provision in most circumstances,
but in circumstances like these
it can be just as powerful
because most contracts include
a force majeure clause.
These clauses excuse a
party from performing
its obligations under the
contract if they are faced
with circumstances beyond
that party's control.
The phrase force majeure is
French for superior force.
The kind of superior
force that would interfere
with the performance of a contract,
and that includes wars, labor disputes,
and extreme weather events.
Generally, the test for whether something
is a force majeure event
requires three specific elements.
Number one, the element
is beyond the control
of the affected party.
Two, the affected party's
ability to perform
its part of the contract
must have been prevented,
impeded, or hindered by the event.
Three, the affected party must have taken
all reasonable steps to avoid or mitigate
the event or its consequences.
There are two categories
of force majeure events.
The first category is
for acts of government
that change the legal
or political environment
that could impact a project or a business.
This could include things
like war, terrorism,
labor strikes, or riots.
The second category
includes natural disasters,
such as floods, earthquakes, hurricanes,
and other weather disturbances that are
sometimes called acts of God.
When a party is affected
by a force majeure
they are usually relieved
from performing the contract.
There may be disputes
about whether that persons
contractual obligations are
canceled or just postponed.
Now, there's no general
statute that defines
what constitutes a force majeure event.
A parties ability to claim
relief for a force majeure event
depends on the way that
the contractual terms
are written and the context
of the rest of the contract.
Most contracts contain a
detailed list of events
that are deemed to be force majeure
and beyond the parties control.
Some contracts include
things like diseases,
pandemics, or epidemics in their list of
naturally occurring events
that may disrupt the contract.
However, if a contract
clause omits language
about diseases and pandemics,
then there will probably be a dispute
about whether a pandemic,
like coronavirus,
is included in a force majeure event.
For example, if the contract
lists a bunch of categories
that do constitute a force majeure,
then the fact that a
pandemic is not listed in it
could be evidence that a
pandemic is not covered.
If there is vague language that says
that a force majeure can be anything
like an example of the
things that are given,
then you have a better argument.
But there's no federal law that says
these particular things are
considered force majeure.
But if you are looking
through your own contract
or your own terms and conditions,
here's a couple examples of
what force majeure clauses
look like so you'll know what to look for.
Notwithstanding anything to
the contrary contained herein,
neither party shall be liable
for any delays or failures
in performance resulting from acts beyond
its reasonable control
including, without limitation,
acts of God, acts of war or terrorism,
shortage of supply,
breakdowns or malfunctions,
interruptions or malfunction
of computer facilities,
or loss of data due to power failures
or mechanical difficulties
with information storage
or retrieval systems, labor
difficulties or civil unrest.
Notwithstanding the foregoing,
in the event of such an occurrence,
each party agrees to
make a good faith effort
to perform its obligations hereunder.
So would coronavirus be
a force majeure event
under this clause?
Well, this is why lawyers
are going to outlive everyone
except the cockroaches.
Because lawyers will argue
that the acts of God language
operates as a catchall,
with respect to events
which are beyond the control
of the parties to the contract.
Since a pandemic would be
beyond the reasonable control
of the parties, it seems
like the coronavirus crisis
would be a force majeure event
under this type of clause.
But you can also argue that
since it's not mentioned there,
perhaps it doesn't cover that.
Or that the actual loss
of business is not related
to the coronavirus per
se, but because of acts
of other people who are not
going to various businesses.
You can go either way
on some of these things.
But statements like the
WHO declaring coronavirus
a pandemic is certainly
helpful to consumers
who want to make their case,
as are the statements of
various state governors
who are putting entire states on lockdown.
So in a situation like this,
you can argue that this is
a change in circumstances
of the law that makes
performance impossible,
and you can also argue
that it is a natural event,
like a plague or some other weather event,
such as a natural disaster
that would also be covered
by a force majeure clause.
There are arguments for both sides.
Keep in mind that making this
argument of a force majeure
event doesn't necessarily
mean that the party themselves
needs to test positive for coronavirus.
What we're looking for
here are disruptions
that are the direct result of coronavirus,
like a forced self-isolation
or shutting down a factory.
These are the consequences that impact
a parties ability to fulfill
its contractual obligations.
So for example, think about
all the vendors that were
providing services to
Miami's Ultra Music Festival.
Despite the festival
taking place in Florida,
where apparently anything
goes and there are no laws,
the festival was actually canceled
after Florida's governor
declared a state of emergency.
- That allows us to create
a unified command structure.
It also allows, if need be,
out of state medical personnel
to operate in Florida.
- Since the event was
canceled due to events
beyond their control, most
vendors should be able
to rely on their contract's
force majeure language
to justify not performing the
services under the contract.
If money changed hands,
I would expect that that
money would change hands again
and go back to the original buyer.
But this isn't a silver bullet.
It doesn't work all the time.
For example, if we're talking
about financial agreements,
like an investor's
contract to fund a startup,
a force majeure event
may not excuse investors
from making payments
that they agreed to make
under a contract.
This is what happened in
the 2008 financial meltdown,
which resulted in many
lawsuits about whether
the financial crisis
was a qualifying event
for force majeure purposes.
Most courts interpreted force
majeure clauses very narrowly.
Market forces didn't
count as a force majeure
unless the specific financial scenario
was spelled out in the clause.
Some people also unhappily discovered
that market forces were directly excluded
by the contract as an
excuse for non-performance.
That surely resulted in a
lot of angry phone calls
to the parties lawyers,
which keeps us employed too.
But force majeure clauses are not
a get out of jail free card.
They don't normally
operate to excuse a party
from making rent payments,
operating expenses,
or loan payments.
But in a situation like this,
with a once in a century
pandemic, all bets are off.
Lawyers are going to be
arguing over these clauses
until we die, which for some of us,
may be pretty soon.
But force majeure is not
the only argument available
to consumers and people
that are trying to get out
of a contract or not pay something.
If a pandemic isn't
included in the contract
or isn't interpreted
to be in the contract,
then the parties might have
to rely on other defenses
that excuse them from performing.
Under American law, the
defenses of frustration
and impossibility may apply.
These defenses are usually
interpreted narrowly,
and they usually require
two considerations.
Number one, whether the
subject matter of the contract
or the means of performance
has been destroyed
such that performance is
rendered objectively impossible.
Two, whether the central
purpose of the contract
has been frustrated or
the contract has become
radically different from
what was contemplated
by the parties at the time
they agreed on the terms.
Many US states have adopted
the Uniform Commercial Code, or UCC.
The UCC applies when you buy
a good generally speaking.
The UCC includes an excuse
where performance has been made
"impracticable by the
occurrence of an event,"
"the non-occurrence of
which was a basic assumption
"on which the contract was made."
So sorry for the double
negative, but in other words,
something that the contract
assumed wouldn't happen.
This defense might work
in a scenario where
a state governor has canceled an event
because it would be attended
by more than 50 people.
If the event that needed to occur
was a gathering of thousands of people,
such as those attending
the music festival,
then arguably the inability
to gather in a group
because it was made illegal could justify
non-performance as impracticable,
which takes me to the
sexiest legal topic of all.
I saved the best for
last, insurance policies.
Now, if a party to a contract
can't meet its obligations
due to the coronavirus outbreak,
you probably need to find out if insurance
will cover you losses.
Sometimes it will.
Many commercial property
insurance policies
provide business interruption coverage.
But companies covered by these policies
won't be able to invoke
them unless they show
direct physical loss to
property of the insured,
its customers, or its suppliers.
Commercial insurers also
sell specific products
dealing with force majeure,
political risk insurance,
or trade disruption insurance.
Sometimes a policy that would
otherwise cover these things
have what's called a rider,
which excludes the specific
occurrence of things.
You'll often see a terrorism rider,
that if your store was
bombed by a terrorist
then the insurance doesn't
apply in that particular case.
So you have to check not
only the policy itself,
but the riders that go
along with the policy.
If you're an individual,
you might check your homeowners insurance,
you might check your renters insurance.
Hell, you might try your car insurance.
Because consumers also have insurance
implications to consider.
Many travelers buy travel
insurance to protect them
from things like a deadly
pandemic that restricts travel.
But if you think that
your insurance company
does have you covered
you may be disappointed,
because insurance companies are terrible.
Once again, you have to
look to the fine print,
and this is, frankly,
just always good advice.
Many travel insurance companies
exclude health epidemics
or pandemics in their standard policies.
They won't even refund
travelers who are afraid
to travel because of the virus.
If you plan to go later in the year,
you might buy a policy that has a cancel
for any reason clause.
However, some insurance
companies are already limiting
the number of cancel
for any reason policies
that they're going to
sell in this environment.
Now, that is largely the bad news.
But let me give you some good news.
It looks like help for small
businesses is on the way.
It's going to depend on what
federal relief is passed
by congress and state laws
will vary state by state.
But everyone is on board
to try and help out
as many people as possible.
Now, I can't go into
detail about all of these
different relief laws, mainly
because they don't yet exist.
The debate is going on in congress.
But the good news is that it seems like
everyone is on board with trying to help
as many people for as long as possible.
Because, really, we only recently realized
how serious this whole
coronavirus thing is.
If you want to see my prior video on how
the US government has botched its response
to the coronavirus I'll leave a link
to the descriptions of my
prior video on the subject.
- No, I don't take responsibility at all.
- But as you know, if
you own a small business,
the coronavirus is
probably already disrupting
your ability to stay open
and pay your employees.
Many restaurants are expected to close
for the duration of the lockdown.
Some states have shut down tattoo parlors,
nail salons, restaurants,
and yes, even GameStop.
Any non-essential company
is being shut down.
This means that many businesses
are going to struggle
to survive and it's clear
that the federal government
is trying to get its act together
and trying to help people.
It's just not clear when that
relief is going to happen.
- There's tremendous spirit
to get something done,
so we'll see what happens.
- So you might have to look to your state
and local governments for help.
For example, New York
City Mayor, Bill De Blasio
announced that the city is
offering no-interest loans
to businesses which see sales
decrease by 25% or more.
To qualify, a business must
have fewer than 100 employees.
For businesses with
less than five workers,
the city is offering grants to help cover
40% of payroll costs and
this hopefully will help
people stay employed during
the duration of this pandemic.
Similarly, Seattle Mayor, Jenny Durkan,
will increase funds available
for micro-businesses
to help small companies access SBA loans,
and provide relief for utility payments.
The city is also delaying collection
of business and occupation taxes.
At the federal level,
we are starting to see
mobilization of the administrative state.
The Small Business Administration has
an Economic Injury Disaster Loan Program
that will give low-interest loans
to small businesses and non-profits
that have been severely
impacted by the coronavirus.
Hopefully, this will just
be the tip of the iceberg.
I expect a whole raft of new
and exciting statutory laws
that will help people in this situation,
and all of the fun litigation
that's going to come as a result of it.
But, of course, this is a
constantly evolving situation.
Although we're focused on
the next four to six weeks,
the reality is that
quarantine and isolation
and self-isolation may last
for a lot longer than that.
Of course, the longer
everyday life is disrupted,
the greater economic impact of all
the businesses and contracts.
But if there's one
take-away from all of this,
it's that, as always,
it's the lawyers who are the real heroes
that are looking out for those in need.
Eat it, doctors and nurses.
Now, of course, part of what
got us here is a failure
to understand the exponential
growth of viruses.
and since most of us have
some extra time on our hands,
#quarantinelife, now would be a great time
to learn how to think
through all the kinds of
challenging problems,
including growth functions.
You can do that with Brilliant.
Brilliant is an app with
a huge library of courses
that will help you build
quantitative skills
in math, science, and computer science
with fun and challenging
interactive explorations.
Whether you want to understand
the fundamentals of coding,
stretch your analytical
muscles with logic puzzles,
or dust off your high
school geometry skills
to help your quarantine kids
wit their quarantine homework,
Brilliant has a course that
can help you reach your goal.
With courses for all skill levels,
Brilliant is built for ages 10 to 110.
The app offers short lessons divided into
different math, science, and
computer science subjects
that explain concepts and principles
that you can use to solve problems.
With schools canceled for
the foreseeable future,
Brilliant is a great way for students
to keep their skills sharp.
If you're a college student looking
to get a leg up on the competition,
Brilliant has everything you need
to level up your STEM knowledge.
Best of all, Brilliant is absolutely fun.
There's nothing worse than listening to
hours of boring lectures by old teachers
standing at a chalkboard.
But Brilliant lets you learn by doing,
which is scientifically proven to be
the most effective way
to master any new skill.
Within Brilliant's library
you'll find courses and topics
like calculus and linear algebra and math
that applies to trading and finance.
You'll also find courses
on gravitational physics,
astronomy, and machine learning.
One of my favorite courses is logic.
The logic course covers liar
and truth-teller riddles,
logical fallacies, machine logic,
and even some strategic game theory.
Learning the principles
of logic is essential
for lawyers, doctors, and nurses.
But believe me, I know the
thought of cracking open
a logic textbook makes you
want to run for the hills.
That's where Brilliant's method
makes the biggest difference.
Brilliant's clever and fun videos
will show you puzzles and riddles
and give you the tools
you need to solve them.
You can sign up and start
learning for free today
at Brilliant.org/LegalEagle.
The first 200 people who
sign up will also get
20% off their annual subscription.
So just go to Brilliant.org/LegalEagle,
or just click the link in the description
to get 20% off of your
subscription to Brilliant.
Plus, clicking on the link
really helps out this channel.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments,
and check out this playlist over here
where I explore all the other
legal issues of the day,
like how the US botched its
response to the COVID-19.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.